oh no this could actually work
whoops gonna be a long day this looks
kind of crazy
this is very strange it's a great idea
see something new every day huh i think
this is one of the best things i've ever
made
[Music]
welcome back to chef out of water i'm
alexis the chef who's always
up for a challenge i've taken to you
internet to see what appliance i should
make a three
course meal with i'll be tasting
everything myself so i hope it goes well
let's see what you've chosen
[Music]
i've had nightmares about this moment
i've like had this fear
i've known this in my heart that this
was coming but this is gonna be hard
look at this
surface area i'll figure it out i'll
figure it out my confidence level is a
three
[Music]
first off i'm wondering how hot all of
these tools get you know but a hair
dryer
i can't imagine it gets very hot
[Music]
140 degrees there's not much you can do
with that
curling iron gets between 200 and 300
degrees
usually that feels a little more
promising okay what about a hair
straightener hair straighteners up to
450.
i mean 450 we can do something with that
right my confidence level's actually
rising i think i'd put myself at
maybe a six at this point ideas are
starting to flow
i'm still feeling pretty nervous but i
actually have a plan i'm gonna start
backwards like i usually do with dessert
i'm gonna make chocolate covered
strawberries with a magic shell
sounds pretty simple but i'm using hair
tools so we'll see how that works out
i had an idea that if i put some
chocolate in a bowl
and then put it over the hair
straightener and also use the hair dryer
the chocolate might melt oh god
[Music]
shoot i'm gonna see if just the hair
dryer works
it's gonna be a long day
yes this is gonna work this is gonna
work
starting to melt thank you i'm gonna add
a little bit of coconut oil
that's how it gets that magic shell
this is looking so beautiful
okay i'm gonna grab some strawberries
and
dip them see what happens luckily these
are very small strawberries
so wow
i'm shocked impressed proud
i mean this might like this could
actually work
at this point my confidence has really
shot up i feel like i'm an
eight right now let's not get too crazy
but i'm feeling good and it dries
so fast that's the joy of a magic shell
i assume the same thing is going to work
with white chocolate
i don't know why it shouldn't i think
i'm just going to do some like little
decorations so i need
less chocolate
[Music]
i think it should work
polka dotted chocolate covered
strawberries made with a hair dryer
gonna pop these in the fridge move on to
my next course
for my appetizer course i'm gonna make
blini through like little russian
pancakes that get creme fresh and smoked
salmon
sometimes caviar if you're really fancy
and they're usually really small so i
think that'll help me here
but i'm gonna try to make them on the
hair straightener
we'll see what happens got buckwheat
flour and
all purpose flour pinch of salt a little
bit of baking powder
and just whisk this together for the wet
ingredients i need this
butter to be melted so i thought i could
just use the hair dryer again
i'm gonna make the executive decision
that that's enough butter it's like a
slip and slide over here
and a little bit of milk
now wet to the dry
okay well that was pretty easy and i
wonder if i should
cover this in tin foil
this looks kind of crazy it's not super
secure but
it's okay and i've got this little
cookie cutter
which is actually like kind of the size
that you would want blainey to be anyway
and it barely fits
on top so you just spray this
cookie cutter down and then
i'm just gonna pour the batter ah i
wonder if i
hold this will be like kind of steam it
this is very strange i don't know what
the cook time on a strainer is
if i was doing this on the stove a
minute or two and then you flip them
which i haven't quite gone there yet
it's bubbling it's cooking so crazy
and and you can hear it
kind of sizzling oh god oh god
okay okay i think with this little plate
if i just have four of these that's like
the perfect appetizer for one i think i
need to
wrap the hair straightener more securely
in the foil first
and i'm gonna use butter instead of the
canola oil
batter hopefully it's fine
it smells delicious okay
perfect so i'm just going to do like
a little bit of creme fraiche smoked
salmon
and then any sprig of dill these are
gorgeous
i honestly don't think anyone would know
they were made with a hair strainer
my confidence is back up to an 8.5
i'm gonna clean this up and move on to
my last course
for my last course i'm going to make a
sandwich which sounds kind of basic but
this sandwich is going to have
steak and grilled onions and blue cheese
pretty classic combination
and i'm gonna try to use all three hair
tools
see how it works first i'm gonna start
with my onion
drizzle with some olive oil my idea was
that i could just put the onions like
right in between
[Music]
you can hear it already onions and a
curling iron
see something new every day huh it
smells pretty good
while the onions are going i'm gonna
move on to my steak they're definitely
getting color on them
it's not quite even i think letting some
of it hang off i thought i could kind of
like smush it back under
but i think it all needs to be under the
kind of like clamp
of the curling iron nice
okay onions they're going just gonna
season the
steak with salt and pepper wow okay
look at that color it's perfect softened
golden brown five tiny onions
straightener is ready put some olive oil
on it
try with this one
the meat is changing color which is
great looks a little gray
these are going to be mini sandwiches oh
there is
a tiny tiny bit of color
[Music]
that is some pretty good color
might be a little overdone but i wish i
could taste it
i don't know how this is going to turn
out
[Music]
they look kind of gray and sad right now
but at least i'll be disguising them in
a sandwich
okay my onions and my sake are done i'm
gonna clean this up
before i move on to the bread so i was
thinking that i could cut the crust off
and i'm gonna butter it on both sides so
that
hopefully the bread will get like extra
golden brown a little bit of blue cheese
a few onions the steak
i think it's gonna work like the way
i've envisioned this it's like golden
brown
beautiful maybe the blue cheese gets a
tiny bit melty
oh no oh no no no no it just
fits oh my god
it's definitely flattening like a panini
there's no color yet it just looks like
it's drenched in butter
[Music]
i spoke too soon it's a great idea
okay it's certainly not what i
envisioned
but it smells amazing i think the flavor
is gonna be insane but it just
looks like bad my confidence level
flavor wise
10. my confidence level aesthetically
is like a one i'll try the other one
with a little bit higher heat wow i was
right
i mean honestly i don't think it's gonna
get better than this
i wish you could smell it though it
smells amazing
i think after all of this i deserve to
eat this food
it's taste test time
okay so here's the thing these two look
the prettiest but i'm most excited about
eating this
disaster but like aesthetically
wow first up my little blini with smoked
salmon
you would literally never know they're
amazing
wow honestly 10 out of 10. that is
so good now for this
the bread was the wrong choice
aesthetically but
flavor-wise this is so good i think this
is one of the best things i've ever made
on this show
no why 11 out of 10. i kid you not
chocolate-covered strawberries oh my god
i mean they look adorable
i mean you can't really go wrong
a great day honestly i exceeded my
expectations today
this was amazing this was such a great
day i feel like it was unexpected
it was weird but turned out really well
let me know in the comments
which one of these dishes you would want
to eat and let me know if you try making
it yourself
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you